eh ben mon gars dans 6h30 t2
tirant co pour te faire chier tu vas
avoir du français ensuite des
mathématiques et tu auras bien latrines
parce que ce sera le matin direction
salle de bain pour de prendre un petit
bain histoire de tron l'axé avant
d'attaquer la journée et puis l'après
midi du haut rhin science et vie ce sera
trop bof bof tu penseras un calme et tu
auras trop envie de rentrer plein de
pipe tout ça sur ses vieux type qui
campe avec leur temps
quoi
et le soir en rentrant manger tout ça
t'as pas le temps d'allumer ras la
console on etc et des kikoolol et à 1h
du mat tir à te faire des pâtes marauder
lens bat had et des ump dont tu iras de
piété
marre de ces cinq journées
vivement les vacances que je sois plus
en prend
[Musique]
oh
la musique a été faite par un faisceau
elle le clip réalisé par soirée
merci à es17 pour m'avoir selmeya la
notation pour voir la page sans tête de
mât